الشهر الماضي عرضنا تقريرا للزميله السمر
بشات عن الحاج زبيده التي قهرت كل الظروف
واصرت على استكمال تعليمها الان مواقع
التواصل ابتلات بصوره نشرتها نجم العالميه
انجلينا جولي على موقع انستغرام للسيدات
المصريه التي حصلت قبل اشهر على شهاده محو
الاميه وعمرها 87 عاما ونشرت انجلينا جولي
صوره للحاج زبيده وهي في لجنه الامتحان عن
طريق خاصيه ستوري عبر انستجرام كنموذج
ناجح تقدمه لجمهورها الذي تفاعل بشكل لافت
مع الصوره اسكران الحاج زبيده كانت قد
اقدمت على دخول امتحانات محو الاميه في
محافظه المنوفيه ضمن مبادره لا اميه مع
تكافل لتحقيق حلم لطالما تمنته وحصلت على
الشهاده التي كانت ترغب بها لتكتب بذلك
قصه ملهمه للكثيرين ممن لم يتعلموا
القراءه والكتابه
[موسيقى]